thanks a lot for joining today and also
thanks a lot for people who are watching
this um for watching the recording so
today I'm gonna be talking about paper
mill specifically about how we can
extend paper mill to serve other use
cases and to make it more flexible
first a few things about me I'm the
co-founder and CEO of Bloomberg we are a
y combinator back company building tools
Building open source tools for data
science and I'm also a former data
scientist so I encountered so many
struggles with the tooling and and all
the challenges that we have to overcome
so that's why I decided to start the
company and start building better tools
for data science
okay so let's start with some background
we're gonna be talking about paper mill
so let's um let's explain a little bit
for those who don't know what paper mill
is how does it work essentially
paperment is a package to run notebooks
let's say you have a notebook that
generates a report
maybe you usually open Jupiter lab and
start running sale by sale you generate
the report and then you send that to
somebody else
if you use paper mill you can execute
that notebook from the command line and
I have an example here
once you install pay per Mill you can do
paper mill then your input notebook and
then the output notebook so essentially
you're going to be creating a copy of
the input notebook and the output
notebook will be uh like a fresh real
run of that notebook
and there are several use cases for
Paper Mill as I mentioned before one is
a report generation another can be model
retraining maybe you have a model that
you have on a notebook and the notebook
trains a model maybe turns hyper
parameters and those of the other things
you can pre-run the same Notebook on a
schedule let's say on airflow or any
other scheduler and you can regenerate
your your model uh using paper mill but
just with running the same notebook so
that's what it does like at its core
it's just a way to execute notebooks
from the command line
all right what many people don't know is
that paper mill has an extensible
architecture meaning you can customize
most of what it does and what I'm going
to talk about in this uh in this
presentation is the engines the engines
are how pay per Mill executes notebooks
and they control everything about
execution
meaning that you can customize pretty
much every aspect of execution if you
want
so on the left side of the screen I have
an example engine and you can see that
each engine is defined as a class
and it defines one class method which is
execute management
you'll receive a few parameters from
here because they come from the command
line and all you also receive the
notebook as an argument and inside
you run the notebook right so it's it's
up to you how you manage this logic and
paper mill also offers a few utilities
to make this simpler
on the right side you see how to
register a new engine so paper mill can
find it because most likely if you are
developing a custom paper mill engine
you will ship this as a separate package
so you can do something like pip install
paper mill then pip install my custom
engine right my custom engine is your
third-party engine and it it's
distributed as a package
so if if you're developing a python
package
you can create these file called
setup.pi
and here you are going to configure this
is the file that you use to configure
any python package there are other ways
but this is kind of the traditional way
and here in one of the configuration
settings you set entry points
this is how pay per Mill is able to
recognize your new engine so you do
paper mill engine
and then you have a list
with a few elements and in this uh here
I'm just registering one engine which is
called my engine
and then I'm telling paper mill that it
can find my engine in the engines.pi in
the class with name my engine so that's
how we do it we create a new class
and then we register that new engine and
then we can distribute this package so
other people can use it
now if everything goes well and let's
assume that we built we already have
paper mill installed and we already did
pip install my engine
then we can use the engine argument
to ex to use paper mill cells we are
still using paper mill input notebook
output notebook
and we are using this argument engine
and we are telling PayPal to use a new
engine in this case it would be
our custom engine
all right so now let's talk about some
interesting use cases and of course here
you can do any kind of customizations
that you want but I'm going to show you
three use cases that we have found
really really useful for practitioners
the first one is notebook profiling
if you use paper mill the default engine
such as this part of the command
you won't be able to monitor the
resources that your notebook is
consuming
that's because pay per Mill creates once
a second process so this is your payment
pay payment process
and when you start executing your
notebook it will create a second process
and this second process is the one that
executes the notebook so if you start
monitoring this process
you won't you will see that it doesn't
use much CPU or much memory because it's
just sending the code to this second
process and executing it this is the one
that's doing the heavy lifting so
there's no easy way to monitor this
notebook execution and in many cases you
may want to do that for example if your
notebook is running out of memory or
maybe you want to know if you are
actually using all the course in your
computer you may want to monitor
if you want to do a notebook profiling
you can use our custom package plumber
engine which exit which implements an
engine that executes everything in the
same process
you can uh get it it's also open source
so you can get it from here and once you
install it
you can run it with the engine argument
so I'm going to show demos for all these
use cases but I'll leave it at the end I
first want to explain the use cases and
then at the end I'll share the the demo
the live demo
okay so this is what happens if you use
the default engine you I'm using this
memory profiler package that allows me
to profile memory and on the left side
you see the result if I execute with the
traditional the the default paper mill
engine you'll see that the graph goes up
and then stays the same
is not able to monitor anything in the
notebook if I use the profiling engine
you'll see there's a difference what I'm
doing with this notebook is I'm just
allocating a larger numpy arrays so I
create one array then a few more than a
few more and you can see the bumps in
memory usage
right so that that's one of the first
use cases notebook profile
okay now Second Use case notebook
debugging this is also really
interesting because if you are if you're
a paper mill user you may have
encountered this in the past
let's say that you are training a model
and this model takes three four hours to
train and you are running you are
executing this with paper mill if your
notebook fails it will become really
difficult to debug one of the benefits
of paper mill is that if your notebook
fails mid execution you can still see
the notebook and up until to that sale
you'll be able to see the outputs and it
that helps with debugging the problem is
if is if you forgot to print any of
these variables or maybe you have a few
data frames and it's a bit hard to
understand what's going on
so
if you are using the default paper mill
engine that's all you got they executed
notebook with the error message and
that's it
so the Second Use case for customizing
pay per Mill is improving the debugging
so to do that we use debug later which
is also a package that we develop
the book later allows you to serialize
the state of the Python interpreter when
your notebook crashes it's also open
source so you can get it from here
and we integrated that with pay per Mill
so if your notebook crashes even
remotely so even if you are running this
notebook in a ec2 machine it still works
and that's actually the most common use
case because if you're sending something
to a remote machine and it crashes then
it's convenient to have more powerful
debugging tools
so it's really simple to use and it's
kind of the same idea right you you
installed the custom engine
and then you pass
the debug later engine
and I'll show you a little demo here
okay so hope uh looks like it isn't
playing but no worries I'll show you the
live demo in a second let's move on to
the final use case
all right final one this is my favorite
one because it's also because this is
the latest one that we did so experiment
tracking
there are many experiment trackers for
machine learning like ml flow but most
of them require you to add custom code
to your to your notebook and onto your
scripts to log whatever you want to log
uh for example you might be training a
model and you may want to log the some
metrics maybe accuracy precision recall
and maybe a few plots right so on your
right side I have an example and I'm
logging a few plots for each model
confusion Matrix Precision recall curve
and the classification report
now with this custom engine what you can
do is automatically load
the variables in your notebook not not
all of them there's a way to specify
which which ones you want to log because
for example you don't want to log all
the training data right
the benefit is that you don't have to
add any extra code what this goes to
mention does is it runs sale by sale and
then it looks for the variables that you
want to serialize
it stores all those values in a SQL
database and then you can use SQL to
analyze performance compare your
experiments
have some summary tables like this and
many other things I'm going to show you
this in the demo
we recently released a blog post on
these new experiment tracker so you can
look at it with more detail at
plumber.io blog slash experiment Dash
tracking
okay now let me
share the most exciting part of this
which is the demo
okay so let's start with um
let's start with the profiling one so
let me open this
so you have it handy
hope the text size is large enough
and we are going to be looking at the
arrays.ipient B so let me show you
let me show you that notebook okay
so we are going to do some notebook
profiling and in this notebook as you
can see I am creating a numpy array with
1 Million numbers
then I'm sleeping for three seconds then
another array
and sleeping for another another three
seconds so if we do memory profiling on
this notebook what we are going to see
is that a big bump in memory usage
because of this then it's going to stay
the same for three seconds and then
another bump here right well of course
we have some overhead because when we
start the python interpreter we need to
allocate some memory
um so that's what we are going to see
great now let me show you what happens
if I use the default pay per Mill engine
so I'm going to do improv improv is the
utility that we use to profile memory
and then we need to execute the command
so it's going to be sorry it's it's m
Prof run then pay per Mill
and erase
this is going to take a few seconds
okay now we do emperor of plot
and you'll see that it stays the same
right it increases a bit and then stays
the same we are not able to profile this
notebook
now let's execute it again but let's
pass engine
well there's a typo here they should be
profiling
filing
let's wait for a few seconds
and let's do n plus plot
and now you see the difference right in
the previous version we had a flat thing
here and now we see the little bumps
because we are allocating more resources
for the non-buya array
great so that's the first use case
now let's go and show the second one
debugging
so let me open this one
let me open this serial division
notebook
okay so now imagine
this is a really simple notebook right
so I I am just creating a numpy array
actually two one here one here
and then creating a matplotally plot
scatter plot
then a data frame
and then this is where things get
interesting because I'm crushing this
notebook on purpose of course in a real
world use case you you would you won't
crush your notebooks on purpose but this
is just so we know exactly what's going
on
all right so imagine this is some fancy
notebook that we have to run on an ec2
machine
we of course don't know that this is
going to crash and we do pay-per-mill
zero division
let's use the default engine for now
so this is going to start running the
notebook and you see what we get here
right we get division by zero and then
it crashes let's look at the output
notebook so I passed out dot I prime B
let's open it
and you see that paper mill is telling
us an exception encounter in cell number
five and if I click on this
I see the traceback right and I can also
see the outputs of the cells up until
this point there isn't anything below
um
and we are able to see the the outputs
now this is convenient but many times
it's not enough many times we want to
explore the variables the values
and maybe run some code to understand
what's going on this is a really simple
case but in in a real uh use case it
would be a lot more complex
so now let's see what happens if we use
engine
debug later
okay so now we see a really similar
traceback except we have these small
short message at the end it's telling us
it serialized the traceback to this
jupiter.dump file and we can start
debugging with this command
okay let's do it
so
just to to recap what we did we rerun
The Notebook with the the new debug
later
um engine and it created a new file for
us so now let's assume these failed on
an ec2 machine and we want to understand
what happened with our notebook
now we can run this command dltr
jupiter.dom
and then it starts a debugging session
for us so we can start printing the
values of the variables we can um let's
let's go back to the notebook so we have
X Y these are the arrays we are not
printing them right so we don't know
their values
and we also have the data frame
and those are the three variables that
we have
now since we are using the debug later
engine we can do X
and we can also see the type I think
this it will work let's see yeah so it's
an array it's X it's y you can print the
values and bf
EF head so we can interactively explore
the variables and these will make things
a lot easier for us to explore and to
debug this notebook now we can do we can
do this as many times as we want like if
we maybe a colleague of us knows this
code better than us we can send the
jupiter.f file to this person and
they'll be able to do the same thing as
many times as they want
these are really convenient way to debug
notebooks that you are running remotely
okay final use case experiment tracking
let me close this
okay now I'm gonna be using the python
API because it's a lot more convenient
since I'm gonna be doing experiment
tracking I want to run many experiments
and then analyze the results so I'm
gonna be exporting plumber engine and
then the track execution
so first I import these packages then
this is going this is a loop that's
going to train uh 45 experiments I think
so it will it's going to take about a
minute or so to finish
I'll explain the code essentially what
I'm doing is I am generating am I am
training uh many random forest
classifiers from scikit-learn and I'm
changing the parameters so number of
estimators from 5 to 50 max depth from
well 5 10 and no Max No Limit and the
Criterion Genie entropy and log loss
here I am running all my experiments so
you can see I ran 30 so far and my code
is actually in this feed dot ipin b uh
notebook so let me open it really
quickly
it's a really simple notebook
it just takes uh generates some uh
sample training set the same for all
experiments I'm setting the random State
here then split between drink and test
then uh fitting date classifier
band generating a Class A classification
report again the accuracy getting a few
extra metrics
confusion made generating a confusion
Matrix and the classification report
also as a plot and then the Precision
recall plot
okay
it's almost done oh it's actually done
yep
so now let's uh see what happened what
we did is this new engine logged all and
actually one important thing we are not
have we are not adding any new Imports
to this notebook it's just a notebook
that prints a model it doesn't have
anything like import tracker it
automatically logs the last variable on
each cell it's going to log accuracy
precision recall F1 and then these three
plots and it's sending those to a sqlite
database
so let me initialize my tracker
and now I am gonna run a SQL query to
extract
the information that I want so the F1
score confusion Matrix Precision recall
classification report ordered
experiments by F1 score so I get the
ones with the the highest F1 Score first
and you can see that here right so my
best experiment had a 0.8 well this is
actually pretty close right 0.8 F1 score
and I see the plots here
and I can zoom into uh any any plot that
I want so I can do confusion Matrix and
now I have these buttons that allow me
to switch between the plots from my best
experiment and the second best
experiment
I'm gonna zoom out so you can see the
plot
okay
um I can also do a few other things for
example since I can use SQL I can do
things like grouping so remember this is
a random Forest I want to know what's
the effect of the number of estimators
in the accuracy for example so what I
can do is I can take my experiments
group my by number of estimators and
then take the mean of all of these
statistics accuracy precision recall on
F1
I can run this
and I get this table now I can generate
a plot that tells me how the metrics
change depending on the number of
estimators so that's what I do here
and now you see
that as I increase the number of
estimators my performance increases
right let's look for example at accuracy
accuracy started as like this is like
0.73 with five estimators
we get to 10 estimators this is like
0.75.76 by the time we reach 25
estimators this is um like 0.77 and
increasing from 25 to 50 doesn't
increase performance that much
and we were able to do this really
quickly because of this flexibility
right we're able to run SQL queries
and um yeah it's it's really really
flexible okay so that's uh that's for
the demo now let me finish
a few more slides and then I'll open it
for questions now Beyond paper mill we
have a package called plumber uh paper
mill allows you to run a single notebook
now in many cases you may want to
orchestrate multi-stage workflows for
example you may have five notebooks
maybe for loading data cleaning data
generating uh some features training
some models in those cases you want to
create a multi-stage workflow a biplane
you can use plumber for that and
actually plumber uses pay per Mill under
under the hood with our custom engines
to orchestrate the execution
other benefits is that you can run the
notebooks in parallel so if you have
multiple notebooks that are independent
of each other plumber can execute them
at the same time
you can also run them in the cloud you
can easily export your workflows to run
on kubernetes our airflow slurm and a
few others
and of course it comes with the custom
engines that I explain like profiling
debugging and experiment tracker and you
can get it from GitHub so github.com
and that's it so here uh here's my
contact in case you want to ask me any
many any questions or you have any
issues maybe you try to reproduce the
demo my email my Twitter or my LinkedIn
now uh we still have time for questions
so feel free to ask
all right thank you Edward uh yeah let's
see a few questions from the from the
comments the first one will be are there
limitations to this debug later State
storing if this is possible in the
general sense it opens the door too many
interesting use cases like save pointing
debuggers or notebooks yeah that's a
great question so
uh we use some
I forgot the name of the library that we
used to serialize the by default we only
see realize uh dictionaries lists
numbers
um and if you install this optional
package then it can serialize everything
that's why when I show the demo it was
able to serialize and serialize the
numpy arrays now that's an important
question because if you are dealing with
really large data sets the dump file
that it generates it's going to become
really really big right so I would say
the only limitation is make sure that
you have enough space to store all these
variables especially if you your
notebook is reading large files
all right
and um
that's one question actually me
personally I've been working with paper
mail and notebook execution a lot I've
got some questions to ask if you don't
mind
um yeah so throughout the process of
like uh orchestrating or executing
notebooks how would you be recommending
people to like um deal with the
authentication process would that be a
tax stored in the notebook itself or you
could it could be like baked in the
environment
authentication you said right yeah yeah
imagine like if uh like uh data you have
like DB connection client uh getting
spawned in your notebook or in your code
and how would you recommend us to do the
authentic authentication because like in
for a lot of firms the the the
um the text authentication was like
access key access ID is not allowed
yeah that's that's a good point so I
could say a few things if
many of our customers use AWS and they
use many AWS services so what we
recommend there is to have
um permissions on the instances that
they use that so give the instances that
run the notebooks enough permissions to
access
only the resources that they need for
example
when they are running this workflows in
the cloud the instance that runs the
notebook has access to that specific
specific bucket where they upload the
output notebook they got it where they
download the input
um
input data and for example the redshift
and all those things so it takes a lot
of work to make sure that you're only
giving those permissions but I think
it's the safest alternative now it
becomes a little tricky when you are
interacting with non-aw services or like
if you're on on gcp as well right like
any non-gcp series
um I'm afraid I'm not I'm not an expert
in security
um but I could say if you are using
services from the same Cloud vendor then
there are ways to authenticate those
instances and those containers only with
the permissions that they need
gotcha hence do you think there's any
like possibilities for open source
projects to be working on those Arc
situations with authentications
um or that could be locked into the
vendors well I think there are many many
cases right so I feel like definitely
authentication is a problem so there
might be ways to simplify it but there
are in Enterprises there are so many
different configurations that it becomes
really hard to come up with that generic
solution
gotcha yeah that's a very inspiring
talks throughout the throughout the
whole session like me again I personally
work on those those sort of issues a lot
yeah
um let's see if there's any other
questions on that
I don't see any at this moment
[Music]
um
all right I think that would that be all
for your session that of today yep all
right cool glad to have you and we'll be
moving on to the next topic have a good
day sir thanks a lot